Kashmir is a land of Rich history and
deep spirituality while the last century
has sadly seen a lot of conflict and
violence in the region its beautiful
mountains and Landscape still bear
witness to a people and culture that has
produced some of the greatest luminaries
in human history
from the great foundational figures of
the non-dual tradition called Kashmir
shaibism such as abhinava Gupta with
paladeva and shemaraja to the great Sufi
Saints and Mystics of later periods the
legacy of these men and women can still
be felt in this place
the Sufi tradition of Kashmir is really
unique on its own with the so-called
reishi order at its Center and its
foundational figures such as the Mystic
Saint nund Rishi serving as perfect
examples of the spiritual Legacy of this
region but today we're going to focus on
another figure that was contemporary
with the aforementioned known Rishi a
female Saint who While most firmly
belonging to the Kashmir shivai
tradition also kind of defies any clear
categorization a Mystic woman who is
revered by Muslims and Hindus alike and
an inspiring poet whose beautiful verses
can touch even the modern reader and her
name was Lal dead
[Music]
Lal dead is one of the most
internationally famous figures to come
out of medieval Kashmir she lived her
life as a Wandering ascetic while
composing her famous poems or Vox that
would be orally transmitted for
centuries after her death by people from
different religious and cultural
affiliations
her life and ideas can tell us not only
about these spiritual cultural and
religious environment of 14th century
Kashmir but also about gender and the
role of women in this Society
expectations which very much influenced
the way that she lived her life there
are many biographical accounts of her
life many of which are probably
legendary and it's hard to know much
with certainty indeed the first proper
record of her and her life comes in the
16th century in a text called
by the super figure
although she is more briefly mentioned
in contemporary poetry for instance with
that said she was probably born in the
early years of the 14th century in
Kashmir some have suggested that she was
born and grew up in a village close to
Srinagar she seems to have come from a
brahmana family that's the highest
Priestly cast of the Varna system and
was married off at the age of 12. this
seems to have been a rather unhappy
marriage though as she already showed
science of a devotional Spirit much more
interested in the spiritual Pursuits
than being a wife for example she would
meditate and visit shrines regularly
which angered her husband who treated
her very harshly
this situation came to a climax when she
was around 26 years old and decided to
leave her life behind she left her
family to instead become an aesthetic
and quickly attach herself to the Shiva
saint called said boyu also known as
siddha srikanta
becoming his disciple Lal dead was
initiated into the spiritual tradition
of Kashmir shaivism and was taught by
this Guru until her training was
complete it's after this that Lala which
is another name that she goes by really
comes into her own she leaves the
protection of her Guru and starts
wandering with no home she became a
traveling aesthetic something that was
very unusual for a woman people would
have looked with disdain on her and the
norm-breaking behavior that she part
took in and a large part of her future
life consisted of being shunned by the
society around her this might seem
especially surprising given that she
belonged to the tradition of Kashmir
shaivism as we explored in our full
video on that topic the shy bites
generally were not ascetics or
renunciants instead Kashmir shaibism
emphasized and encouraged living a
householder's life all the great
proponents of the school were Scholars
and teachers engaged in society family
and their work while simultaneously
practicing a deep spirituality that
included these aspects of life this was
in contrast to many other Traditions
such as vedanta where renunciation or
becoming a sannyasan was much more
emphasized
so how come Lal dad didn't follow the
same principle how come she was a
Wandering ascetic unlike her Shiva peers
while the simple answer lies in the fact
that she was a woman women had much
different expectations on them than men
did and it was really difficult to live
a fully spiritual life with all those
expectations that came with being a
woman or being a wife for example the
scholar and translator of LaLa's works
at anjit hoskota says quotes in an ethos
were male shiver questers lived within
Society rather than in Retreat from it
she could not as a woman do likewise
precisely because she was a woman whose
life was far more closely and rigidly
governed by domestic duties and
expectations than a man's she could not
lead a life of spiritual aspiration at
home and so was forced to leave it
thus she became the wandering Lal dead a
female Mystic who experienced ecstatic
visions of the Divine and was shunned by
some but incredibly loved and
inspirational to others in particular
her Fame would spread from the fact that
she started to recite oral poems that
expressed her mystical experiences and
ideas
these short poems called Vox would
quickly Start Spreading and became very
popular among certain groups of people
the kashmiri word vak is related to the
Sanskrit vak which means speech thus the
vox can be translated as something like
sayings or utterances they are indeed
short poems only a few lines each but
often very clear and to the point
significantly these Vox were also
composed in kashmiri which was just
emerging as an independent language and
lalded's poems are some of the earliest
examples of kashmiri literature as such
in these poems we find teachings and
expressions of the highest mystical
States as well as some rare glimpses
into her life for example in some poems
she addresses those people in society
that criticized her for her lifestyle in
one of my favorite books quote let them
hurl a thousand curses at me pain finds
no purchase in my heart
I belong to Shiva can a scatter of Ashes
ruin a mirror a gleams
but most of the poems are dedicated to
the spiritual path and questions of
religious devotion one of the things
that are so interesting about her poems
is that they not only include
expressions of shaiba or Hindu
philosophy but also traces of Islam and
Sufism through Arabic and Persian
phrases
this shouldn't be too surprising given
the fact that Lala lived in a diverse
environment where different religious
Traditions existed simultaneously and
were influenced by each other
in particular there are quite a few
similarities between Islamic teachings
as understood through Sufism and those
of Kashmir shaivism so it would have
been kind of natural to implement some
of the vocabulary from each other
this also becomes clear when we consider
that the Muslims of the irishi Sufi
order still consider Lal dead a founder
of their tradition of sorts
there is indeed some disagreement today
about the religious identity and
affiliation of Lala many Muslims want to
claim that she was a Muslim Sufi
personality through and through while
Hindus will say that she had nothing to
do with Islam and is purely a Hindu shy
of a thinker the reality in my opinion
probably lies somewhere in between it
becomes pretty clear when we read her
poems that she primarily belongs to a
kind of kashmiri shivite tradition in
terms of how she expresses herself and
the Theology and and ideas that she
expresses right they're very shy-vite in
nature from these sort of non-dual
kashmiri shivite tradition in general
but there are traces of other influences
as well and the environment of 14th
century Kashmir was indeed very
different from the very polarized
situation that we find today
thinkers from both of these religious
Traditions so Islam and Hinduism would
sometimes influence each other they were
in dialogue with each other this is a
perfect example of this people you know
Representatives on both sides would
often comfortably step somewhat onto the
other side of the court so to say to be
inspired and influenced by each other
this is a really fascinating environment
in that sense that can seem very foreign
and when we compare it with the
same environment geographically that we
find today but again it's hard not to
see the essential imprint of shaibism in
the expressions of lalded she frequently
exclaims devotional fervor directed at
Shiva and talks about the unitive
experiences as the devotee recognizes
her own reality as that one infinite
Consciousness that is identical to Shiva
quote Lord I have never known who I
really am or you I threw my love away on
this lousy carcass and never figured it
out you're me I'm you
all I ever did was doubt Who Am I who
are you
the tradition of Kashmir shaivism is a
non-dualistic school of thought and
practice within the larger shaiva and
Tantra Traditions its main figures such
as abhinava Gupta all of whom lived in
Kashmir created an amazing synthesis of
ideas and practices that is now called
Kashmir shaibism or tarika shaibism
the philosophical basis of the school is
a strict non-dualism where everything in
existence is but one thing Shiva the
infinite Consciousness and supreme Lord
everything is consciousness takes place
within Consciousness and expresses
Consciousness and that Consciousness is
Shiva
the goal for the shaiba practitioner is
to recognize this essential Oneness of
herself and all things with Shiva even
the multiplicity of the world in all
this diversity is identical to Shiva
without ever neglecting that diversity
as part of the Divine fullness
and these ideas are found all over
lalded's poetry quote
Shiva lives in many places he doesn't
know Hindu from Muslim the self that
lives in you and others that's Shiva get
the measure of Shiva
or quote who sees self as other other as
self whose his day as night night as day
whose mind does not dance between
opposites he alone has seen the teacher
who is first among the gods
in non-dual shaivism this fullness of
Shiva has two aspects one absolute Light
Of Consciousness and the
self-reflexiveness of that Consciousness
identified with Shakti the goddess or
divine feminine
it is this pulsating or vibrating
relationship between Shiva and Shakti
the sexual act within the Oneness of the
Divine that produces the world the world
is created by the power of Shiva which
is Shakti who is imminent in all things
and indeed is identical to them
this relationship of Shiva Shakti is
expressed in one of LaLa's arguably most
beautiful Vox quote I Lala came through
the gates of my soul's Jasmine Garden
and found Shiva and Shakti there Locked
In Love
drunk with joy I threw myself into the
lake of nectar who cares if I'm a dead
woman walking
in all these poems Lal dad talks about
the spiritual path of the Shiva
tradition one that involves a certain
level of asceticism to be sure but also
one that seeks a kind of balance between
two extremes
the Shiva was expected to live actively
in the world after all with that said
this practice did involve a kind of
turning away from harmful inclinations
and desires quote
kill those Road Pirates greed lust and
pride you'd be doing us all a great
service and then you'll figure out how
to reach the true Lord and you'll see
that the world is made of Ash
she would practice austere asceticism
staying away from the fleeting desires
and lusts of this world
particularly those that stem from greed
lust pride and anger but at the same
time like we said and just like the
largest shaiba tradition teaches this
asceticism should never become too
extreme
since Shiva is everything including the
multiplicity of the world sense pleasure
can be enjoyed and even sometimes
reveled in as long as it is understood
in the correct way pursued to get closer
to God and not for its own sake
Lala talks about finding this balance in
the following poem quote gluttony gets
the best table in the town of nowhere
fasting gives your ego a boost slave of
extremes learn the art of balance and
all the closed doors will open at your
touch
while gluttony should be avoided extreme
fasting will give your ego a boost which
is basically the opposite of what you
want so neither of the two extremes are
desirable but rather some kind of
balance in between in these ways Lal dad
often countered many of the customs and
ways of doing things that were prominent
at the time
she often criticizes many common Hindu
practices such as animal sacrifice and
even idol worship
this makes sense within a Kashmir Shiva
framework as that school often neglects
outer practices in favor of
internalizing those practices to where
practice is directed inward within the
field of mind and Consciousness itself
quote my master gave me just one rule
forget the outside get to the inside of
things I Lala took that teaching to
Heart from that day I've danced naked
thus her criticism of many other rituals
are the Hindu religion can often come
off as pretty harsh quote you are sky
and Earth Day wind breath night you are
grain sandal paced flowers water
substance of my offering you who are all
what shall I offer you
Shiva is everything including as she
points out here the very things that are
offered to the Gods in the Puja
ceremonies how can one offer to God what
he already is
and on animal sacrifice she says quote
it covers your shame keeps you from
shivering grass and water are all the
food it asks who taught you priest man
to feed this breathing thing to your
thing of stone
instead she urges us to focus inward to
forget about the outward practices Pious
observances chanting and Sacred
Scriptures as such the answer lies
within quote when the scriptures melt
away the chants remain when the chance
melt away the Mind remains when the Mind
melts away what's left avoid mingles
with the void
when one does this we instead penetrate
into what is truly real into our actual
reality in essence quote I trapped my
breath in the Bellows of my throat a
lamp blazed up inside showed me who I
really was I crossed the darkness
holding fast to that lamp scattering its
light seeds around me as I went
this showed her what she really was she
says in other words she realizes and
recognizes that she is identical to
Shiva that Shiva is all and everything
the infinite Consciousness that is all
things
in actuality things are pretty simple
when we do away with all the complicated
rituals and observances we realize that
the answer was right in front of us all
along quote he laughs when you laugh
sneezes in your sleep yawns for you
coughs for you he bathes every day in
the river of your thoughts he is naked
all year round and walks where you walk
just go up and introduce yourself
it's fascinating that Lal dad basically
offers us a full rundown of the
spiritual path in this way the Vox give
us a view into her mind that she travels
Inward and eventually as she reaches the
ecstatic recognition of reality as it is
exemplified really well in this poem
quote when the dirt was wiped away from
my mind's mirror people knew me for a
lover of God when I saw him there so
close to me he was all I was nothing
it thus becomes pretty clear the
philosophical background that she
belongs to and which she expresses so
beautifully in her many utterances
despite this clear affiliation with the
Shiva tradition in particular there is
still a level of universality in these
poems Lala can speak to a wide audience
and touch us with her deep devotion and
spirituality this is perhaps why she is
so revered by different groups of people
I should mention since I've been quoting
her poems so much here that I'm using
the translations by Ranjit hoskote in
the collection called ilala a book and
translation I highly recommend if you
want to dive deeper into the life and
poetry of this great Mystic as we
mentioned earlier she lived in an
environment of religious diversity there
were Muslims Hindus of all kinds of
affiliations Buddhists and other groups
living within the same regions Lal dead
interacted with the sufis of her day
were probably inspired by them and
indeed inspired them in turn in
particular the stories tell of a close
relationship between lalded and the
great kashmiri Sufi noon Rishi or Sheikh
nurudi nurani he's one of the main
founders of the Rishi Sufi order which
still dominates the region today and
nundrishi is considered one of the great
Saints in kashmiri history one story
tells how nondrishi as a child refused
to be breastfed by his own mother only
taking his sustenance from Lal dead
instead
a story that should probably be read
allegorically to indicate that Lal dad
was a major influence on his Spiritual
Development
some have even suggested that she might
have been a teacher of sorts for the
younger Sufi I think the relationship
between these two figures is fascinating
it it really offers a very concrete
example of the inter-religious dialogue
that were taking place in many regions
and in this region in particular at this
time how figures from these different
religions could see that the
commonalities between these religions
and through that be able to inspire and
have an instigate dialogue between each
other where they could influence and
Inspire each other I think it's really
fascinating but for these reasons Lal
dad is claimed by different communities
the sufis of the Rishi order see her as
one of their own foundational figures
due to her relationship with people like
nondrishi whereas shaivas and Hindus
claim her for themselves it can often
become a political discussion in that
way but as we've seen the situation is a
bit more complicated than that Lala is
thus given many different names Lal dead
which is a very University except one
means something like
others call her laleshwari and still
others call her Lala arifa meaning
something like lala the Noah or Lala the
Gnostic in Arabic regardless what name
she goes by her Vox or poems her
utterances have been spread and
transmitted by people from different
cultural and and religious backgrounds
in Kashmir as representing one of the
absolute Treasures of kashmiri
literature Lala died somewhere around
1373 where her Legacy still lives on in
Kashmir and around the world as an
inspirational figure to people of all
walks of life cultures and religions
I'll see you next time
[Music]